[Music]
hey by the way i meant to ask you
because we we watched we watched your
videos yesterday because now we're
talking about you got to get into that
yeah because this is great because well
now we talked about your twitter thing
but this is what first off i got to say
you ripping that dude's mask off was so
[ __ ] funny that was precision bro
that was certain that was a ninja that
was a ninja move you went yoink and took
it off and
so i thought it was funny that they they
kept like
they kept like trying to hit you guys
and punch you guys did the cops do
anything about that did they care or
well that was at the very beginning
there was no cops i was actually the one
that called the cops and then they kept
you know once two cops came they had no
idea what was going on they see all
these christian fascist guys not not me
but this john doyle who's actually at
the place too he's like an honest
christian fascist type guy that's like
you know no homophobes allowed type guy
and i like john right but he's like you
know he's pretty extreme he'll admit
that he's extreme and there's like
people on the megaphone these cops are
like what the hell is going on why are
they protesting this small bar
and that was the problem guys i'm sure
y'all don't care if people are doing
drag brunch i could care less i give a
[ __ ] yeah i don't care i've lived in
tampa
yes i'm saying it dude i don't give two
[ __ ] but this is dude you guys know
this too about drug culture they say
with a drug dealer the first time your
first hit's always free that's what the
vibe was guys it was like oh let me get
these kids in this bar like i remember
and it kind of i imagined it too like on
a football recruiting trip you know
where like the seniors take you to the
bar it was like that type of vibe like
come to this cool bar we're going to
show you like this cool edginess and
they were doing it with little kids guys
like one of some of these kids were
autistic like say what you will i'm not
i don't want to ever seem like i have
the moral superiority of anybody because
i don't but this was the scum of the
earth every parent there with their kid
was either like a gay parent a parent
that was divorced you know there was
some sort of family drama you could just
tell just their energy was that they
were from broken home energy and they
were basically feasting off these kids
and i'm not speaking hyperbolically like
they were using these kids as like a
source of pride like oh we got kids in
here so whatever what we're doing is
okay because kids are here it was the
weirdest well they're they're they're
trying to dis they're trying to disney
fi their their their little movement
right they're trying to go like and you
know not that disney's not helping
because they are because they're making
all those [ __ ] directions well the
whole rainbow flag was designed for that
with that in mind in the first place was
to make it colorful and inviting to kids
but joe camel yeah and and and it's it's
it's funny because you know you you went
out there and you've done a lot of stuff
right you've done all these town halls
and you've done all these [ __ ] crazy
wild [ __ ] that you've done
but the moment you did this all of a
sudden it's like sorry uh you don't
gonna be on twitter anymore like that's
it that's where the line is drawn but i
think you're right man i think it's 100
like if you try to make this like oh no
this is fun this is normal kids should
be doing this anyway who cares they can
i think it's a weird way of them morally
justifying themselves to themselves
right they're like well how can it be
bad if it brings a smile to my
five-year-old autistic son's face
because he's five he doesn't know any
different you know yeah and people are
like oh you know they're like alex
you're talking about kids shouldn't be
in a bar but a kid can go to the bar at
chili's first of all this wasn't chili's
dude
it says you know a huge sign it says
it's not going to lick itself this is a
sexualization of children and i've never
seen it like live and in person like
this you know this is what they you know
they're always like disney's groomers
disney's groomers now they have some
weird stuff in disney's movies but this
is like concrete grooming right in front
of your face and this is why i actually
i have a little bit of empathy for these
people is a lot of these people there
they were abused sexually that's why
like i know mers kind of likes the
predator poacher stuff but i kind of
hate it and the reason why i kind of
hate it because you know all those guys
were molested as a kid so it's kind of
like you know it's just kind of just
sucks they're because they were you know
abused they fee they pass it forward no
but you know what that's there's no
[ __ ] excuse there's no [ __ ] yeah
you're right there's never excuse me
there's nothing i had [ __ ] happen to me
as a kid and i know a whole host of
people that have had [ __ ] happen to them
as a kid and they're not out [ __ ] you
know adding to the abuse pipeline so no
you know yeah dude you're 100 right
because i dated girls that were abused
by you know serious older people and
they were you know they probably had a
little mental health issue but they
would never abuse a kid no you're you're
right that's no excuse but i gotta i
gotta say this though it does look like
and i i don't know because there's very
few little angles of the inside of this
little thing but i i seem to get at
least a little bit of a white pill it
didn't look like
a ton of people brought their kids at
least it looked like a small group of
really [ __ ] up evil people but
it it looked like a lot of adults in
there a lot you know what i noticed
did you see a lot of a lot of a lot of
kids or was it i know i was like
probably 12 to 15. so i mean that was
the one thing i took some comfort in it
i'm like okay well at least only some of
you were complete psychopaths like it
wasn't packed
but but to play contrary and that bar it
might seem like it's kind of big because
the people that went in there they did
great all dough and isabel o'reilly you
know they actually filmed good but dude
where this angle right now imagine
you're looking now these people are
sitting on a bar stool that's like the
whole bar it's really a dive bar that's
like the entire bar from that wall to
the front door and then right behind you
is a bar with a glass mirror there's
probably from like from this angle
there's probably like two or three more
i mean probably five feet so it is it is
a small place that's what i'm saying it
might look kind of big because this
angle you're seeing the whole entire
length of it but it was a really it was
like it said like a dive bar yeah
so so it's it's funny because you know
you you brought you brought that up and
i and i want you to because i don't know
did you did you see that the news report
they did on it uh the local national
park all the puff pieces no but show me
what you're saying absolutely
they're specifically one that i want you
to hear their excuse okay right after
this watch
here
tonight throughout the week aj cruz has
worked at mr misters for about two years
listen to this he said today's event
allows people to express themselves
there was a lot less people drinking
today so that would make it more
kid-friendly
there was a lot less people drinking
alex alex you know what this guy turned
me on you now you're right alex there
was a lot of less people drinking so it
was fine that would be like that would
be like somebody being like wait you
drove my kid with what after you had
drinks i'd be like yeah i drank a lot
less than i usually drink though you
know what i mean okay i drove your kids
home and i may have had like five or six
drinks but normally by that hour i would
have had eight or nine drinks
than normal but people have clips this
is the people that were like you know uh
exposing them that the the owner trey
stewart this is why he knew me he does a
podcast with the real housewives of
dallas girl stephanie holman and i've
trolled the real housewives when i first
started creating content they were
filming and i went and just in the
middle of it like a dick had pulled out
my phone and just messed up their whole
set and was like i'm filming too i'm
filming too
you guys need to watch it it's like one
of my older videos on instagram but what
i'm saying is so all the real housewives
of dallas they all know me that's why he
knows me because i trolled him and do
they have videos of him talking about
their podcast you know freely like how
we talk about how that club they do
poppers all the time how they're always
on papers so yeah i mean they might have
been on a little less drugs but they
were taking key bumps and doing poppers
and on they were they were popping molly
for sure yeah but that but no but that's
okay but that excuse is the worst excuse
i've ever
i've ever heard and yeah a lot of these
were puff pieces to be fair with this
one i will give credit to wfaa at least
they also gave the side of like a woman
who was disgusted by it she was uh here
this is the other one and they didn't
make her sound like a lunatic
that woman wasn't even there i don't
think uh i guess she sho but apparently
she showed up later i i don't know
crisis actor uh yeah she's a crisis
actors crisis actor alert i don't
recognize her i have for several years
daisy says she first saw a poster oh
there she is outside where she lives i
don't believe that um
that's after it's like over though i
mean no yeah she's they're not that
she's she's not in there during the
nitty-gritty i guess she showed up
afterwards probably after she started
seeing clips because that's the thing
though a lot of these people even if
it's in their neighborhood are busy like
they don't know right unless they're
like really tuned in they wouldn't know
and now i'm sure there's a lot of people
that didn't know this was going on in
this neighborhood until they saw your
videos right until they saw people going
like wait what happened because if not a
lot of these things happen a lot a lot
of people think that this is like oh
this is crazy can't believe this is
happening there's a lot of little towns
this happens in all over the place
people don't know about it because
unless you're really tuned in you're
like uh whatever i'm doing something and
then you then they're doing this at a
gay bar or or or a drag drag queen
library reading and
you know people don't know about it
and i'm not trying to pat myself on the
back but i got two things i got to say
because the drag queen story time in the
library is disgusting but at least there
it's out in the open this place they put
paper over the window like the election
like they they were like trying to hide
this they didn't want people to look in
so that that already is a little sketchy
and and they actually did it then next
sunday there was like a like a family
type pride event where there's pictures
of kids that are at a drag show and it's
be and i'm not patting myself on the
back but because we went there and we
filmed it we documented it and we
organized a protest against it because
libs of tick tock tweeted it that's why
this got the national news and that's
why brian slayton is putting in
legislation so i'm not even trying to
take it as a w i mean maybe a little
small w because it's i guess you know it
brought attention to it um but there
this is you're right this happens all
the time
and then the gay community that have
reached out to me you know i have gay
family and friends they said oh this is
disgusting you know why are they you
know sexualizing children but they said
there's a lot of drag brunches where
people bring their kids that's not that
you know it's not focused mainly towards
kids but there's drag brunches where
people bring their kids all the time